ich merke auf jeden Fall dass das nicht
so einfach ist wie gedacht
man Alter ich bin so busy
ich kann nicht mehr nachdenken es ist
wirklich schlimm Alter und alles ist
nass
meine Güte es ist tap hängt wirklich an
jeder erdenklichen Stelle durch an der
man sich vorstellen kann ist übelst am
pissen
ey Jungs zu mir ehrlich übelst leid ich
hatte so große Pläne ich hatte so viel
vor und das ist dann so endet man hatte
nur eine Chance und die ist jetzt weg
genau vor zwei Jahren habe ich es schon
einmal versucht doch statt nach 7 Tagen
zu triumphieren war nach einem Tag
Schluss Millionen von Menschen haben es
gesehen doch niemand wusste genau warum
ich Bescheid tief in mir drin wusste ich
aber dass ich eigentlich kann klar also
dass ich mit Schweden noch eine Rechnung
offen habe das zu begleichen geht
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden
kämpft ein Mann sieben Tage mit sieben
Gegenständen ums Überleben ich bin
wieder da der erste Versuch endete für
den outdoor-neuling schnell zu mir
ehrlich übelst live Sport und Helme
waren ihm dadurch sicher doch jetzt ist
er zurück an dem Ort an dem alles begann
die Wiedergutmachung keine Kamerateam
Jetzt Geht's Ab kein Kontakt zur
Außenwelt krass ausmachen vollkommene
Isolation
herzlich Willkommen zu Games seven
wie in der echten Staffel auch habe ich
natürlich ein Backup Team bestehend aus
zwei ersthelfernsambrot die rund um die
Uhr abrufbereit sind und mich jederzeit
retten können und bei einer Absicherung
und insbesondere medizinische Versorgung
im echten Leben mindestens genauso
wichtig ist unterstützt klagt nicht nur
dieses Video sondern auch euch bei
Versicherungsfragen in Deutschland gibt
es zwei Versicherungsmodelle gesetzlich
und privat und die gesetzliche Zeit in
vielen Fällen nur ein Bruchteil deswegen
ist sein kann dass sie mit akuten
Zahnschmerzen lange im Wartezimmer
sitzen müsst oder vielleicht sogar gar
nicht dran kommt und euch dann noch eine
dicke Rechnung ein paar Tage später im
Briefkasten erwartet ich selber bin weil
mir meine Gesundheit ziemlich wichtig
ist von einem Jahr selber in einem
private Krankenversicherung gewechselt
lag steht euch als persönlicher
digitaler versicherungsmanager für die
Beratung zu privaten Krankenversicherung
zur Verfügung und zeigt euch auf mit
welcher Versicherung ihr Behandlung von
besten Chefärzten kurzen Wartezeiten und
Kostenübernahme ohne Kopfschmerzen
erhalten könnt hierbei könnt ihr euch
per Chat Mail Telefon oder sogar
videokamer beraten lassen und immer gilt
mit dem Code Dave oder über diesen QR
Code erhaltet ihr durch das Hochladen
drei bestehender Versicherung bis zu 45
Euro in Form eines Shopping Gutscheins
den ihr bei unzähligen Partnern könnt
darunter about you the sound und Adidas
ladet euch also jetzt die klagt App
runter vereinbart einen kostenlosen
Beratungstermin und schaut dass sie
genauso wie ich in diesem Projekt und
auch im echten Leben gut abgesichert
seid vielen Dank fürs möglich machen
dieses Videos und das kommt von ganzem
Herzen sie unterstützen mich seit Jahren
und dafür bin ich extrem dankbar und
euch viel Spaß mit diesem Video
das habe ich mir wirklich selber
zuzuschreiben
zweites Mal Alter
[Musik]
Challenge Nummer eins startet in drei
zwei eins go
Männer tschüsschen
ja
sieht schön trocken aus
[Musik]
ich bin wieder da
es ist alles trocken geblieben
[Musik]
Versuch Nummer zwei
die offene Rechnung die Wiedergutmachung
irgendwas davon sucht euch aus so das
war's dann fährt das Team dass mich
ausgesetzt hat
das ist hoffentlich
hoffentlich der letzte Blick
auf menschlichen Kontakt für die
nächsten sieben Tage
und jetzt gehen wir den perfekten Platz
für den Shelter suchen
Staffel 1 er hat nicht so super optimal
ich lass mein dryback erstmal stehen wir
laufen erstmal ein bisschen hier durch
und gucken
was das hier so zu bieten hat
das hier
sind die miserablen Überbleibsel
des einen Versuchs
hier hängt da irgendein Draht
Feuerstelle
ja davon aus dass Leute nach mir noch
mal da waren weil so viel Feuer habe ich
nicht hinterlassen und ich glaube dass
diese ganzen Stimme auch nicht von mir
sind
[Musik]
direkt zum Start
Geschmacksprobe schmeckt wie E und E
h nee so ein bisschen sauer oh das sieht
aus als hätte hier irgendjemand mal
einen etwas professionelleren Schalter
gebaut
der wir eingestürzt oder jemand hätte
ihn einstürzen lassen
scheinlich
bin ich
hier
mit am besten beraten wahrscheinlich
viel Zeug was mir auf den Kopf fallen
könnte
aber
hier ist er wirklich schon deutlich
dichter ich denke
das könnte der neue Spot sein
Sachen holen Auspacken ich meine
Gegenstände zeigen dann als aller aller
erstes das tat so spannend das ist
wirklich was aushält Spot war es doch
noch nicht
noch mal weiter gelaufen und habe
20 Meter weiter hier so eine Art
Lichtung gefunden aber immer noch von
derselben Baumgruppe geschützt also in
die Richtung ist alles ziemlich perfekt
ist alles ziemlich dicht aber das
schützt mich schon mal sehr gut diese
beiden Bäume hier eignen sich ganz gut
für meinen Tag ja
das könnte es sein denke die beiden
Bäume werdens ich glaube ja dass der
Wind von dort kommt
spann ich hier meinen Tag hier meine
Hängematte
bin ziemlich dicht mittendrin habe die
Bäume hier die mich schützen ist nicht
super weit zum Wasser
vorne steht ein umgekippter Baum aber es
sieht nicht so aus als würde der in
irgendeiner Welt in meine Richtung
kippen jetzt spanne ich als allererstes
mal meinen Tag auf und ich glaube dann
kümmere ich mich den ganzen Tag darum
Feuer Holz zu holen und mich darauf
vorzubereiten dass es irgendwann anfängt
zu regnen weil es wird irgendwann regnen
ich habe mich dafür entschieden nicht
dieselben Gegenstände wie beim ersten
Versuch zu nehmen ich glaube
meine Fehler haben angefangen noch bevor
ich ausgesetzt wurde was gleich
geblieben ist
ist der Media Koffer den kennt ihr alle
wir haben GoPro powerbanks Ladekabel
Akkus ich habe noch eine 360° Kamera mit
und ich habe auch meine große Kamera
dabei einfach weil ich gerne ein paar
hochauflösendere Aufnahmen machen wollen
würde ist alles voll diesen Scheiß
fliegen ich muss möglichst schnell
irgendwie ein Feuer anbekommen das alles
gleich geblieben
Medikits ein grünes ein schwarzes
erster Gegenstand und das auch der erste
Unterschied Paracord
zweiter Gegenstand Messer größeres ein
besseres als letztes Mal
eine Hängematte
ich werde es nicht hinbekommen ohne
Erfahrung mir ein Bett zu bauen das
trocken ist dass mir vernünftigen Schlaf
bietet und deswegen habe ich mich für
eine Hängematte entschieden
Schlafsack derselbe wie es letzte Mal
Decathlon bis
angeblich null Grad null bis fünf Grad
ich bin sehr gespannt
ein Tag drei mal drei Meter
eine Säge hatte ich beim letzten mal
auch dabei aber diesmal eine
handkettensäge ist kleiner kann ich mehr
Meter mitmachen weiß ich noch nicht ob
das schlau ist aber ich denke das wird
mir beim Feuerholz ordentlich helfen
und ein Feuerzeug wie beim letzten Mal
großes big Feuerzeug keine Faxen ich
muss nichts beweisen was ich nicht kann
dann hier mit Feuerstahl anzutreten wäre
falsch für meine Zwecke so dann wollen
wir mal ne
dieser Stamm muss weg ich hoffe ich
kriege den bewegt
ansonsten wäre es schlecht
ich will in meinem traumszenario
ein eyframe Tab so Abspann hier an der
Seite wird relativ flach runtergehen
weil der Baum da an der Seite stört und
dann
die eine Seite mir hier quasi in meine
offene camprichtung wo ich dich diese
Seite von dem Bäumen geschützt bin dass
ich die Seite so aufmachen kann wenn ich
das möchte das wäre so mein
traumszenario schauen wir mal
ich habe mich genau wie Bommel in
Staffel 1 für eine Hängematte mit
Moskitonetz entschieden ich glaube in
Staffel 1 war das noch
regelkonform in Staffel 2 galt das dann
schon als zwei Gegenstände aber wir
machen hier Staffel 1
ja wie wunderbar es funktioniert
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott das hängt
es hängt
Hürde fast sagen das ist jetzt erstmal
als Provisorium
sollte es jetzt anfangen zu regnen
wunderbar funktioniert
was ich nicht gesehen habe also schaut
euch das mal an ist doch super hier
schön alles dicht wunderbar sich nicht
gesehen habe bevor ich das aufgestellt
habe
beim reinschlagen von diesem Hering hier
floriert eine riesige ameisenkultur die
jetzt schon überall auf dem rumkrabbeln
was natürlich richtig scheiße ist also
werde ich vermutlich früher oder später
den Spot wechseln müssen vielleicht
vielleicht freuen wir uns auch an ich
denke eher nicht jetzt Hängematte rein
den Boden da vielleicht ein bisschen
fertig machen alles aus dem Weg was ich
da nicht haben will
und dann steht mein Setup um den Regen
zu überstehen dann ist das hier noch
nicht wohnlich aber dann komme ich durch
den Regen
ich kann mich eh nicht dagegen wehren
Alter ich bin komplett Alter
oh mein Gott
wunderbar
richtig hoch
so vielleicht
was für ein Segen
also
es ist nicht perfekt
ich lieg halb im Ameisenhaufen hier sind
übelst viele
Fliege Viecher die Neigung meiner
Hängematte ist eigentlich deutlich zu
steil
aber ich liege erstmal nicht direkt auf
dem Boden
es gilt es jetzt für mich noch
auszukleiden
ich mache es genauso wie Bommel und leg
mir hier alles an frischen Tannen Essen
drunter was ich kriegen kann
Kleide mir das komplett aus dass das
möglichst einfach nicht dass die Nässe
nicht hoch durchzieht habe ich genug
Platz mein scheiß abzulegen links und
rechts
[Musik]
fühlt sich jetzt schon nach einem
ordentlichen Futter an
liegt man wahrscheinlich auch platt
irgendwie so
noch andersrum
das hilft zumindest schon mal dabei
nicht komplett nass zu werden
ja
das ist wunderbar
[Musik]
das ist wirklich anstrengender als man
denkt und als es aussieht auch wenn man
im Prinzip nichts macht
zerrt das schon an den Kräften und auch
viel drüber nachdenkt was man wie man es
machen könnte und so weiter und obwohl
ich jetzt so ein komplettes Standard
Setup gemacht habe ist es einfach das
erste Mal so richtig
dass man das macht
das ist schon richtig geil
das ist einfach wirklich Ruhe das kennt
man gar nicht also selbst im Moment die
ich in Köln oder sonst wo völlig egal an
Ruhe habe es nicht so ruhig
so
ich habe meine Säge
schauen wir mal ob wir ein bisschen
Feuerholz finden
Alter
kein Problem
schauen wir mal
ja da vorne geht es weg weiter
einheimischer Baumfäller meine erste
Ausbeute sieht ein bisschen mager aus
aber ist wirklich schön trockenes Holz
vorne drei Stämme schön trocken sind
okay zweite Position vom Tab
funktioniert
und das ist jetzt eine Höhe in der man
auch vernünftig sich da irgendwie was
freischaufeln kann und so ich habe mich
gerade eben mal Probe gelegen und an der
Seite die Sträucher haben schon ein
bisschen genervt ich brauche noch ein
bisschen mehr unter der unter der
Hängematte aber das ist einfach nervig
dann in so einem aframe mit wenig Platz
zu arbeiten so schmeiße ich die
Hängematte gleich da über die Leine hab
komplett Platz und kann mir den Boden
machen kann mir alles machen und weiß
jetzt auch genau bis wohin die
Feuerstelle gehen darf nicht bis hier
schaut mal
fühlt sich schon richtig heimisch an
schön in der Hängematte hier kommt die
Sonne gerade so leicht durch
und erwärmt das Camp wunderbar
fühlt sich wahrscheinlich
genau bis zum ersten richtigen
Regenschauer so heimisch an
aber wünschen wir es uns mal nicht dabei
so sieht es übrigens nach hinten aus
meinem Camp aus also genau da vorne ist
mein Camp das hier ist quasi eine Insel
das hier ist Moorgebiet man da da ist
auch richtig Wasser also weiter als hier
kann man nicht laufen ist richtig nass
und morrig im Prinzip bin ich hier
trapped sieht von oben und auf den
ersten Blick nicht so aus aber es ist
quasi eine Insel je nachdem wie der
Wasserstand ist wurde mir gestern auch
noch gesagt kann man hier drüber laufen
oder kann man nicht drüber laufen aber
momentan ist scheinbar sehr hoher
Wasserstand
aus
ja aber ich habe ja hier alles was ich
brauche also keinen Grund über diese
Grenzen hinweg zu gehen gehofft hier in
der Region vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Pilz oder so zu finden ja ich würde auch
das sofort wieder tun Pilze essen ich
glaube nämlich nicht dass das zu meinem
Ausscheiden in Staffel 1 geführt hat da
können wir in den nächsten Tagen aber
noch mal in Ruhe drüber reden aber
bisher habe ich keinen einzigen Pilz
gesehen ist auch nicht weiter schlimm
weil bis dato habe ich keinen Hunger
also ich nehme hier damals so eine
kleine Blaubeere mit nach wie vor
sind die überall schmecken wunderbar
aber richtigen Hunger habe ich nicht
für so ein
kleinem für so eine kleine Aufmunterung
sind die schon echt gut
verrückt ich weiß nicht ob ich schon
gesagt habe aber diese Dinger hier kann
man scheinbar auch essen
guckt euch das an
sieht aus wie zwei Welten die Sonne
und der Untergang
nicht wundern ihr seht die ganze Zeit
einen zweiten dry back in dem zweiten
drybag ist diese Kamera Stative Linsen
und so weiter weil ich es mir nicht
entgehen lassen wollte hier auch noch
ein paar vernünftige Aufnahmen
mitzunehmen also wenn ihr euch wundert
wo die Aufnahmen herkommen hier und aus
diesem
aber es hat
krank gedonnert
ich packe auf safety mal an mein Puls
ist direkt übelst hochgegangen
da hinten
hier wunderbar
hier richtig dunkel und sieht da hinten
richtig wie es am Regnen ist
ganz genau sehen da ist wieder klarer
Sonnenschein
[Musik]
unsere Richtung kommen ich trink was und
dann geht's wieder zurück ins Camp
es kommt wie es kommt
das ist Mutter Natur und ich kann nichts
dagegen tun
und dann hier wieder absolute Idylle
ich spanne einfach mal ab auf safety
kann ich einfach reingehen das war kein
Stress machen
das Ding sieht für meinen Geschmack
ziemlich okay gespannt aus also klar es
ist nicht perfekt aber es ist okay die
bleiben stehen
Paracord bleibt da dran hier
dann kann ich morgen wenn ich will das
Ding einfach wieder aufspannen mein Holz
ist im Trockenen nicht alles aber der
Großteil
der Donner kann mir nichts
und genau in diesem Moment geht's los
ich verdrückt mich rein
geht los
wegen alles in Sicherheit packen den
neuen Akku in die GoPro
dann geht's ab Alter das kommt aber
wirklich was runter
ich liege in der Hängematte
und das nicht mehr weil es regnet
sondern einfach weil diese Viecher
wieder da sind ich glaube jeden Morgen
und jeden Abend wenn es so
dämmerungsmäßig ist und das fuckt so ab
also entweder ich machen Feuer oder ich
bleibe hier liegen aber ich glaube für
heute bleibe ich hier liegen
Müll
das haben wir jetzt davon
das liege ich hier im Decathlon
Schlafsack
ist eigentlich noch relativ hell draußen
ich habe leider Zero Ahnung wie viel Uhr
es ist aber scheinbar ist der Tag
unendlich
also wirklich der Tag fühlt sich an als
würde er nicht zu Ende gehen ich hätte
vor fünf Stunden pennen gehen können
habe es nicht gemacht weil ich die Nacht
irgendwie rumbekommen will
ich habe das ja schon mal gesagt das ist
Nacht ist so das eine Ding von dem ich
mich wirklich fürchte ich glaube nicht
dass ich mich verletze ich will gehe
jetzt bestimmt nicht perfekt mit allen
Sachen um aber ganz ganz dumm stell ich
mich in den meisten Fällen
wahrscheinlich nicht an und der Tag hört
nicht auf aber man merkt schon dass es
jetzt in Richtung Abend und Dämmerung
geht aber es ist lange lange noch nicht
an dem Punkt wo es wirklich dunkel ist
es wird nur schlimmer
ich bin sehr gespannt was da aus der
Nacht wird es ist immer noch hell
und ich liege schon wirklich wirklich
lange rum
mal sehen aber jetzt so gute Luft
vielleicht mache ich auch morgen auf und
mir geht's besser denn hier kann auch
sein
es ist Zeit in einer hoffentlich
ereignislose Nacht zu starten ich werde
jetzt in diesem Moment versuchen zu
schlafen es ist wieder unheimlich viel
Zeit vergangen aber es tut sich nichts
gute Nacht ich hoffe wir sehen uns
morgen früh und damit erst in Folge 2
wieder
[Musik]